en velay merci elle a effectivement
deuxième partie de cette voix est libre
sur la réforme des collèges avec gilles
platret maire ump de châlons sur saône
isabelle cheville est pour la fsu
stéphane guiguet pour le parti
socialiste et jan chan divers pour le
se-unsa on avait attaqué le chapitre
l'esprit de cette réforme juste avant
les les infos de midi moi j'avais noté
la phrase de il faut que je la retrouve
de
2,2 de jean pierre chevènement
qui en fait ancien ministre d'éducation
de gauche qui a critiqué un égalitarisme
niveleur en gros on enlève aux meilleurs
mais est ce que c'est la bonne solution
jan chan divers
n'enlève omeyer on en enlève pas déjà on
essaie on fait pour pouvoir donner - les
rêves des infections euros anglais qui
avaient un peu plus de riz retrouvée
l'enlève concrètement on lui enlève des
jeux retrouvé un noeud pays sur sur une
des sections européennes par exemple on
peut on peut retrouver les choses il y
aura peut-être moins d'heures mais en
tout cas on ne classera pas actuellement
le collège il est ni unique née juste et
encore moins efficace voilà il n'est pas
du tout efficace il faut changer
complètement le modèle vous avez des
élèves qui ont des chances chez eux dans
leur famille d'avoir on n'arrive pas
égaux en sixième il faut arriver à c'est
pas à l'école de creuser ces inégalités
actuellement c'est le cas quand vous moi
même j'ai moi même mes parents qui m'ont
donné une bonne éducation
ils m'ont dit quand ils ont eu le choix
à faire il faut aller dans la classe
latin parce que tu seras sûr d'avoir une
bonne classe donc c'est encore le quart
20 25 ans après non on peut pas comme sa
classe et d'entré vous avez j'entendais
tout à l'heure les des classes
j'entendais tout à l'heure dans l'est
dans l'éducation prioritaire vous avez
des fonds des collèges où il ya de la
ghettoïsation vous avez les blancs dans
dans la classe latin et vous avez les
élèves de couleur dans les autres
classes on peut pas rester comme ça et
on ne donne pas de réponse monsieur
platret quand on vous dit tout à l'heure
on n'a pas la même vision mais ces
décrocheurs et 6 550 mille élèves ont
continué d'augmenter pendant
la période de droite et puis je trouve
du coup ce débat je le dise à ses
devoirs le snes fsu qui a combattu
pendant des années des années la
politique de droite et d'être sur ce
plateau les uns à côté des autres ça va
c'est nous les avons biais d un côté les
autres c'est nous qui sommes assez
étonnant et comme mes trois
contradicteurs sont sondés lui moi je ne
suis pas élu donc ou par les
personnels non non non non mais vous un
je parle au nom du se-unsa et des
enseignants les attaques sur les les
attaques sur les élites fin jeudi à sa
suffit pas à masquer les faiblesses de
votre opposition se rappelle qu'il ya
déjà eus la projet de réforme sur les
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
il y avait quand même qu'était une
demande de l'ailé gauche de votre parti
on va dire est qu'ils ont été vécue de
la même manière à l'époque j'entends
bien mais là en l'occurrence on parle du
collège et ce qui est intéressant je
reviens à cette enquête pisa parce qu'il
faut il faut se pencher aussi sur les
chiffres c'est important et nous
comparer aux autres pays parce qu'il va
bien dans le système éducatif voir ce
qui va mal et les élites ne sont pas du
tout menacé pour le coup le fossé est en
train de s'agrandir notamment au collège
entre les bons élèves et les moins bons
c'est là le problème il est là il est
pas le problème des idées et on sait
très bien que les bons élèves
continueront à poursuivre leur chemin et
et par des jeux de de choix dans les ep
y trouveront tout à fait leurs comptes
voilà le lez le débat sur les élites ou
dire c'est pour masquer le reste masquer
le vide et c'est vous qui entretenait ce
débat c'est pas de moi du tout est bien
sûr non pas du fond par l'essentiel mais
quand vous avez passé votre sang a
tweeté monsieur-là serait avec des enfin
vous référer à un peu plus vous verrez
vous y prendrez beaucoup de plaisir sont
réduites et les emails le tweet de
monsieur sarkozy qui nous explique moins
d'heures en allemand quand on connaît
l'histoire de notre pays c'est quand
même scandaleux je veux dire résumer la
réforme des retraites à ça c'est quand
même
c'est la seule chose qu'on entend depuis
des semaines pourrait décéder des
caricatures débat voilà vous êtes pas
pourquoi le gouvernement allemand
lui-même s'émeut de ce que les classes
bilangues risque de faire baisser le
niveau de l'apprentissage vous savez on
est à 15 % en france en allemagne en est
à 19 % les allemands font tout pour que
leurs jeunes continuent d'apprendre le
français et nous nous faisons tout pour
que ça soit l' inverse on a beau dire
qu'on ouvre des postes capes mais s'il
n'y a pas de candidat parce qu'on les
arts a découragé par ailleurs parce
qu'ils n'auront pas appris l'allemand
pendant pendant le collège donc on est
en train de casser un axe fondamental la
construction européenne qui est la
connaissance réciproque des deux peuples
et l'apprentissage réciproque des
langues donc ça c'est quelque chose de
mal alors après moi je veux bien que
vous fassiez tous les procès d'intention
sur twitter sur facebook ou sur ce que
vous voulez on assume complètement la
ville y aurait là qu'un également
opposés non pas simplement au parti
socialiste mais à une partie de la
gauche parce qu'en réalité vous êtes les
défenseurs tous les deux d'une vision
qui n'embrassent pas la gauche en
totalité pourquoi sinon vous auriez
contre vous monsieur chevènement
monsieur ayrault monsieur lang et des
tas d'autres personnalités de gauche qui
vous disent comme nous le disons aussi
que la réforme va dans le mauvais sens
qu'elle conduit à l'égalitarisme qu'elle
est qu'elle méconnaît les principes de
transmission des valeurs de la
république pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous le
dit pourquoi est-ce que chevènement vous
le dis il est droit de chevènement à ma
connaissance en temps de rigueur
complète que vous le placez comme tel en
tentant de dire qu'on casse la
construction européenne avec la réforme
du collège limoux témoin et la naissance
les émois des deux ans la la ça ne l'est
sûrement rire mais bien sûr que si c'est
pas extraordinaire mais c'est fait ça
sur un plateau de télévision je veux
dire vrai je n'avais jamais entendu ça
et on réalise que la négligence
complètement des spas de la négligent
ignorance réciproque de deux peuples et
vous verrez ce qui finira par arriver
puisque a besoin de se connaître pour
contrôler il répondait elle est toujours
fait on introduit une deuxième langue en
cinquième et quand on se penche
précisément sur la réforme on constate
que ça va aboutir quand même on va
multiplier à peu près par trois les
postes de professeurs d'allemand quatre
ans voilà ça c'est la réalité des
chiffres c'est la réalité des élèves
alors oui et puis elle prend les loups
les heures d'allemand cartes font
également vous parler des professeurs
quand même incroyable ballet vont
apprendre l'allemand ça sera leur choix
juste valeur ils font et je dois vous
avez répondu à la question comme
actuellement mais comme actuellement
c'est des choix il y en aura moins
qu'avant bien sûr qu'elle est sûr que
s'il avait le nombre de postes au capes
également très bien heureusement non
mais attendez attendez sauf que les
viviers à l'université se sont asséchés
donc déjà ils vont à mon avis vont pas
tous être couverts j'espère me tromper
hamon c'est bien pour ça qu'elle ment
sur la rue aux nations en question pour
relancer peut-être terminée ce chapitre
là skis a pas de risque et vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez que cette réforme
pour certaines familles poussent
certaines familles à mettre leurs
enfants dans l'enseignement privé est ce
qu a pas de risque on se retrouve en
france avec un peu comme aux états unis
un enseignement public pour les plus
pauvres et l'enseignement privé pour le
reste de la population c'est une
question l'a entendue dans le débat je
vous pose la question il ya le candidat
d'une re dire à tout le monde que
l'enseignement privé appliquera cette
réforme également ce qui n'est pas le
cas pour la réforme des rythmes qui
avait fait longuement débat il n'ya il
ya un an de ça
non il n'y a pas de raison de fuites moi
et moi je voudrais les heures qui sont
peut-être reprises comme vous dites aux
20 % de gens qui sont de d'élèves qui
sont déjà favorisés vont être
redistribués à tout le monde et on n'a
pas du tout parlé tout à l'heure
d'accompagnement personnalisé très très
peu et et des petits groupes qu'est ce
que veulent les enseignants vous dites
que vous parlez au nom des enseignants
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent au collège
actuellement il ils disent il ya trop
d'élèves dans les classes on veut
travailler en petits groupes vous prenez
un collège lambda pour donner un exemple
pour que tout le monde comprenne et
notamment les parents dans un hexagone
dans un collège avec quatre classes par
niveau vous passer de 8 heures
actuellement d'accompagnement
personnalisé comme ça ou en petit groupe
à 48 heures avec la réforme de petits
groupes donc on peut on va du coup
répondre aussi à des attentes
d'enseignants alors oui il faut prendre
les moyens parce qu'on va pas laisser
les élèves à 35 heures dans la semaine
où 36 ou 37 ans va pas multiplient kane
sall et les dispositifs donc oui il faut
prendre des moyens aux fondamentaux moi
je ne sais pas ce que c'est les
fondamentaux je suis prof de ps je pense
que le ps c'est important pour la simple
et savoirs fondamentaux
non mais quand vous dites disciplines
fondamentales ce que c'est ça qu'il ya
derrière vos mots le ps en termes de
santé publique pour l'ail savoureux est
brute est le savoir elle en manteau mais
peuvent être peuvent être si je peux
finir peuvent être aussi un enjeu majeur
et donc il n'y a pas de raison de faire
la différence entre les disciplines les
horaires sont déjà adaptés au savoir
lire écrire compter etc je sais ce que
c'est que les les savoirs fondamentaux
quand même et donc on peut prendre un
petit peu partout pour redistribuer à
tous je vous coupe yates en hiver parce
qu'il nous reste poli minute cinq
minutes pour qu'on parle de la suite qui
va se passer maintenant les décrets sans
passer des textes ont passé isabelle
cheville et il va se passer quoi
mais ni deux secondes deux secondes sur
sur l'accompagnement personnalisé que je
raconte pas mais
là il n'y a pas les moyens dans les
heures non affectés y a que deux il ya
que deux heures 75 par division et du
cou
l'accompagnement personnalisé risque de
se faire comme au lycée en classe
entière donc voilà on sait tous que je
voulais dire qu'est ce qui va se passer
nous on demande l'abrogation des décrets
on va avoir recours en juin plusieurs
journées d'action est déjà le cadre le 4
juin et
le 9 juin est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est qu'un suivi mais je pose la
question est ce que vous pensez qu'à
tromper jeudi déjà ce que c'est le 4
juin on va faire des réunions
d'information aux parents et aux
enseignants dont quatre villes du
département je parle du département de
côte-d'or pour le moment donc à beaune
montbard aussonne et dijon informé les
parts de la grange le fond de la réforme
sachant quand même que j'ai pour ce cas
des parents la fcpe la principale
associant deux parents est favorable à
la réforme oui est-ce qu'on ne les a pas
entendus dans l'instant pas non je
signale moi non plus et j'explique aussi
que la fcpe n'est pas présente sur ce
plateau je le dis qu'on aura des
spectateurs parce qu'il ya le congrès de
la fcpe ce week-end berlin n'est pas
opposée et que la paix n'est pas opposé
mais pour cela il est important de
souligner aussi ce jour là pour le coup
c'est pas une réforme idéologique vous
l'aï bien puisque la paix peut quand
même placé à droite et n'est vraiment
pas défavorable donc pour les biens
au
logis gilles platret françois bayrou
devant d'une grande manif nationale je
suis pas sûr que ça va ça va arriver je
partage plutôt votre avis je suis pas
sûr que ça arrive moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on ait un débat qui soit
relancée donc l'idée à un moment donné
que le gouvernement prenne conscience
qu'il ya une vraie question cruciale sur
ce dossier qui n'est pas une question de
droite gauche on la montre et je pense
aujourd'hui qui tue parce que le
syndicat et l'égarement représenté à mes
côtés n'a pas vocation à intégrer l'ump
demain donc arnaud données ont été assez
patient pas bêtement est assez confiant
très peu de chance mais au moins on peut
avoir un débat et sur des questions
fondamentales le poser sur la place
publique donc ce que nous nous demandons
c'est que le débat reviennent notamment
parlement même si la loi était votée il
est toujours loisible un premier
ministre de provoquer un débat sur toute
question au sein de l'assemblée et moi
je trouvais extraordinaire que le parti
socialiste qui est le grand parti de la
défense du parlementarisme dit
aujourd'hui c'est pas la peine d'en
débattre à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat donc nous nous demandons que ce
débat ait lieu et nous continuerons
d'amener les propositions parce que
cette dérive parce que son étude ne se
limite pas au collège ce que nous
voudrions aussi posé sur la table c'est
si le collège rural c'est aussi parce
que l'école élémentaire ne va pas bien
c'est aussi parce que l'école maternelle
ne va pas bien on a des mesures à
prendre des choses à intensifier à
chalon sur saône moi je vais vous le
dire on lance par exemple à la rentrée
une classe spécifique pour l'accueil des
moins de trois ans parce que ça commence
de jouer maintenant la lutte contre
l'égalité elle se joue dès les tout
petits de n'en rien dû éviter de
supprimer afin de dynamiser le crédit
aux écoles dans votre ville acharné sur
ce lors du dernier budget primitif
africain vous avez une exactitude à
chalon sur saône nous mettons en place
dans le quartier le plus défavorisé de
chalon à la rentrée une classe pour les
jo nous empêche aussi d'ouvrir le débat
sur chalon sur saône on n'y arrivera pas
même sens divers il nous reste deux
minutes
c'est intéressant justement parce que la
cua les profs vont appliquer cette
réforme il faut l'accompagner donc moi
je il va falloir de l'accompagnement et
des bonnets de formation il ya un an
pour ça donc dès septembre il faut
accompagner les enseignants pour
travailler autrement parce que c'est pas
de temps toutes les formations initiales
mais avec une application du coup pour
septembre 2016 donc
c'est comme les rythmes 1 on va pas se
le cacher
mais la refondation pour répondre
justement une meilleure liaison entre
l'école et le collège c'est notamment ce
qui a été instauré avec les cycles et le
sic cm1 cm2 6e avec des meilleurs
passages que les parents qui le voient
c'est ça c'est la grande différence
entre l'école primaire et de lâcher lors
de leurs enfants avec cette multitude de
disciplines donc regroupement un peu les
choses s'apaisent est satisfait ça va
avancer ça va l'écouter on est dans un
monde hyper connecté où l'information
circule à toute vitesse ou dans une
économie de la connaissance où on n'a
pas beaucoup de place quand même pour
les non diplômés je crois que le collège
doit être un collège exigeant et qu'on
doit former des citoyens qui sont à la
fois autonome et responsable
voilà donc la loi pour la refondation
dans sa globalité s'inscrit dans ce
cadre là et je crois que lé ni
défavorable aux enseignants ni
défavorable aux élèves qu'on va dans le
bon sens concret des postes qu'on a
instauré un climat de dialogue et je
l'éprouvé tout à l'heure avec le conseil
supérieur de l'éducation que ce dialogue
a lieu depuis des mois et qu'on va
continuer et moi je fais confiance aux
enseignants je fais confiance au chef
d'établissement confiance à l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative pour que ce
projet aboutisse et qu'il soit vraiment
une lutte pour l'inégalité dans toute
l'école de la république je vous coupe
les cheveux ou encore de la musique non
là je vais t'appeler xi check c'est
l'heure de la fin la mission merci à
tous les quatre c'est devenu de base
merci rendez vous samedi prochain même
heure même endroit pour un nouveau
numéro de la voie est libre bon week-end
au revoir